peu
[Musique]
officiers sous-officiers et soldats de
la 2e division blindée à vous sentir et
votre énergie précis appelez vous
coupera allons son pari elle vous
retrouvé vos camarades rechercher vos
chefs et continuer en répandant dans le
pays le patriotisme qui a fait notre
force
[Musique]
il est 10h15 ce 28 novembre 1947 sur le
terrain d'aviation d'oran la cenjp à
quentin mitchell b 25 un ancien
bombardier transformé en avion de
transport d'école
à bord il y a probablement l'homme le
plus populaire de france
à cette époque le général leclerc alors
inspecteur des forces armées en afrique
du nord
sur le terrain il y a également deux
autres avions
mais les pilotes eux ont refusé de
prendre l'air pourquoi parce que la
météo est extrêmement mauvaise et on
annonce notamment une tempête de sable
en direction de colomb béchar or c'est
pour colomb béchar que s'est envolé
l'avion du général leclerc il n'arrivera
jamais quelques temps plus tard l'avion
sortant de la crasse percutera le
remblai de la voie ferrée méditerranée
niger
une explosion du froid ya une immense
gerbe de feu il ne reste plus rien de
leclerc il ne reste plus rien des onze
personnes qui l'accompagnaient 17
officiers des quatre membres de
l'équipage la nouvelle a été accueillie
par tous les français comme une tragédie
[Musique]
peu de jours sont passés depuis qu'à
l'ombre du clocher de strasbourg les
actualités françaises film est pour la
dernière fois le général leclerc qu'un
accident d'avion vient d'enlever à la
france qu'il a si bien servi
on n'a pas oublié l'épopée dont leclerc
fut à la fois l'auteur est le héros
leclerc ce n'était plus le général
inconnu du tchad c'était déjà une
légende en marche
une légende qui jour après jour
s'inscrivait dans les mémoires
françaises
[Musique]
leclerc est mort le silence tombe sur
cette grande figure le silence tombe
mais non l'oubli n'est cependant que les
français pleurait leclet que les
journaux étaient pleins de détails sur
la catastrophe
une information singulière était portée
à la connaissance du public
il y avait douze personnes dans l'avion
de leclerc et pourtant sur place
on avait relevé 13 cadavres que voulait
dire
ce 13e canada toutes les hypothèses
étaient avancées et naturellement
bientôt un mot était prononcée attentats
avait-on assassiné le général leclerc
on n'a pas répondu à l'époque cette
question après 40 ans puisque il ya 40
ans cette année que le clairet m'at on
se pose toujours la même question mais
avant d'ouvrir avec vous le dossier je
crois que il faut rencontrer le général
leclerc lui-même le voir vivre le suivre
à la trace
voyez-vous quand on ouvre eux ces
vieilles chronique qui illustrent toute
notre histoire on rencontre à chaque
instant des personnages extraordinaires
des destins inouïe et on se dit mais oui
c'était autrefois ces chevaliers ces
conquérants
ces personnages hors série il vivait au
moyen âge il vivait en un temps qui
n'est plus le nôtre aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de ces personnes
eh bien je crois que nous avons tort de
penser cela ait une vie comme celle du
général leclerc justement est là pour
nous prouver le contraire
alors c'est un très vieux non
par ce qui ne s'appelait pas leclerc
vous le savez bien il s'appelait
philippe de hauteclocque et on trouve
des holt colloque au 12e siècle il ya un
vibert de rules clock qui est chevalier
du comte de saint paul
on trouve deux holt clock qui suivent
saint louis en tunisie et des hôtes bloc
qu'on la trouve toutes les batailles qui
jalonnent
la marche de notre histoire
et le conte adrien de hauteclocque dans
sa 51ème année s'engage au premier jour
de la guerre en 1914 il va faire les
quatre années de guerre et en rapportera
la rosette de la légion d'honneur alors
comment voulez-vous que son fils
philippe qu'est né en 1902 lorsqu'il a
passé ses baccalauréats lorsqu'on lui
demande qu'est ce que tu veux faire
n'est pas répondu faire cincy
alors ce philippe de hauteclocque il est
de taille moyenne il est mince seck vif
un regard énergique avec quand on s'y
attend le moins de la tendresse
c'est avant tout un homme de certitudes
il a la foi en dieu
une foi chevillée au corps et jusqu'à
son dernier moment cette fois les draps
à vivre et à agir
il a la foi en son pays les hôtes clock
sont attachés charnellement à la france
c'est un caractère d'ailleurs on dit
traditionnellement tous les hôtes clope
au mauvais caractère eu la très mauvais
caractère philippe de hauteclocque dès
ses 18 ans ni le mauvais caractère il
n'accepte pas la contradiction il
n'accepte pas qu'on lui résiste alors
tout à coup il éclate
ils prononcent des paroles blessantes et
ça durera toute sa vie même quand il
sera héros mais on n'acceptera toujours
de lui cette façon d'agir parce qu'il
sait revenir vers celui qui l'a injurié
et d'une façon tellement naïve qu'elle
séduit et qu'on lui pardonne tout alors
pour le moment il sort de saint cyr il
entre à saumur pour un an
et voilà sa première affectation trêve
il n'y va pas tout seul il vient de se
marier une jeune fille de versailles
jeune et jolie marie thérèse de gargan
et puis après tu rêves ce sera le maroc
il arrive un peu après la bataille parce
que le
la rébellion de la belle crime et jubile
et pourtant il se bat et il essuie sa
première blessure instructeur à saint
cyr
et puis il va présenter l'école de
guerre il écrit à ses proches je n'ai
aucune chance d'être reçus il est reçu
major
ce qui n'est pas mal politiquement
qu'est ce qu'il est philippe dole coque
et bien il le suit maurras comme tout
une grande partie des jeunes gens de sa
génération il faut lui dire je pense que
cette époque que la jeunesse se divise
entre maurrassien et jean l'extrême
gauche communistes ou socialistes il
faut être extrémiste quand on a 18 ans
quand on a 20 ans mais il suit maurras
aussi parce que maurras dénonce le
danger allemand et pour lui c'est le
danger essentiel il a 37 ans il est
capitaine
il a déjà six enfants sans domicile
c'est un château les hauteclocque ont
toujours des châteaux il est né au
château de bel wash son père
[Musique]
et ce père a fait don jeunes ménages
d'un autre château voisin en picardie le
château de tahiti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va partir en 1939 pour la guerre lors
cette guerre c'est la drôle de guerre
personne ne se bat mais lui se bat parce
que il commande une patrouille dans la
forêt de vente et il est au contact des
allemands échappe nulle part avec sa
patronne
[Musique]
où
ils s'enfoncent en territoire allemand
une nuit il s'enfonce de quatre kilos
mais c'est un beau succès dans une
guerre qui en comporte peu le 10 mai 40
et bien l'armée française se réveille
l'armée française enlisé sort de son
immobilisme
pourquoi parce que les allemands
attaquent alors la division où il est
chef d'état major est envoyée après da
puisque hitler envahit la hollande et la
belgique mais elle ne va pas plus loin
que quand elle est littéralement figé
sur place par la force de feu des
blindés allemands et par les
bombardements en piqué des choucas
[Musique]
l'europe lit commence la division après
s'être battus dans la forêt de mormal se
retrouve dans l'île et là les allemands
l'encerclant
la division va être faite prisonnière
c'est pour demain pour après demain au
plus tard et philippe de hauteclocque ne
veut pas être prises
il est une chance très grand ce
capitaine n'a pas de soldats sous ses
ordres chef d'état major
alors il va trouver le général et lui
dit je ne sers à rien ici est-ce que je
peux tenter ma chance je le général
après avoir hésité lui dit allez-y
au revoir hauteclocque je vous envie ils
fuient line vers le sud
vol une bicyclette vo lun tin et 20 km
plus loin se trouve face à face avec les
allemands on lui tire dessus se réfugie
dans un champ de seigle on n'a pas
encore fait la moisson il laisse pas
c'est la colonne et la fuite va
commencer des jours pendant lesquels ils
ne marchent que la nuit ils essayent de
sonner de frapper à des maisons lui
ouvre pas c'est un soldat français on a
peur des représailles allemandes
il ne mange pas pendant trois jours
enfin chez un mineur il vole une
casquette qu'on me refuse il a un
imperméable
alors elle peut passer pour un civil non
ils rencontrent encore des allemands
cette fois ci on le fait prisonnier à
colonel vall interrogé il jure qu'il est
civil ont fermé dans son imperméable la
casquette vissée sur la tête
sept civils et vous êtes jeune quel âge
avez-vous 37 ans et comment n'êtes vous
pas mobilisés à 37 ans chez six enfants
mon collègue est alors le colonel
s'esclaffe prend à témoin tous ceux qui
nous entourent dire voilà ce que c'est
que la france à 37 ans parce qu'on l'a 6
enfants on n'est pas mobilisée pour
défendre son pays
allez-vous dans monsieur tant pis pour
le mépris 120 euros - il est libre et va
retrouver quand même les français va se
battre en champagne classera blessé à la
tête
c'est affublé d'un énorme pansement
qu'il va s'évader de l'hôpital lorsqu'on
lui annoncera l'arrivée des allemands
[Musique]
il arrive à paris se cacher les
concierges d'un cousin
et c'est là qu'il entend parler de goût
on a signé l'armistice il en était
désespérée mais il paraît qu'un général
à londres parle à la radio qui n'appelle
au conte comment s'appelle-t-il il ne
connaît pas la victoire mais comment il
ya un homme qui ne s'incline pas un
général qui ne s'incline pas en france
un général qui dit qu'on peut continuer
la bataille qu'on n'a pas perdu une
guerre mais une bataille est dans le
moment même on lui parle de de gaulle il
décide de leur joie mais comment faire
un cousin
adolescence descendre vers le sud
or sa femme madame de hauteclocque et
près de libourne avec les enfants elle a
fait l'exact comme tout
alors il part avec le cousin le cousin
le laisse sur la route
la bicyclette qui avait été placée sur
le porte-bagages de la voiture une
[ __ ] le voilà à libourne retrouvailles
avec sa femme et ses enfants et il
annonce un madame de hauteclocque je
vais rejoindre le groupe et elle est à
l'unisson de ses projets ça nous
surprend pas il faut un visa espagnol un
visa portugais parce que c'est par là
qu'on peut rejoindre l'angleterre
alors il part pour bayonne toujours sur
sa bicyclette
et puis là il l'obtient du consul un
visa portugais mais le consul espagnol
refuse le visa c'est que les espagnols
ne veulent pas faire de peine aux
allemands qu'est ce que c'est que ce
capitaine français qui veut partir alors
le voilà qui repart ils passent
clandestinement en zone libre arrive à
pau hélas le consul espagnol lui refuse
également le visent
il saute dans un train le voilà à
perpignan et là il obtient madrid
lisbonne un bateau anglais
il débarque en angleterre on peut pas
garder son nom sa famille est en france
elles risquent des représailles
alors il sera désormais le club c'est un
nom qui est très commun en picardie et
comme s'il voulait marquer ce passage de
hauteclocque à leclerc il achète une
qu'à la halle on est désormais cette can
ne le quittera plus jamais
oh
le 25 juillet 1940 qu'il pénètre dans le
cabinet de travail de charles de vaud le
voilà face à face pour la première fois
et de gaulle est réellement rentrer dans
le but or ce n'est pas une arme et qu'il
colle et leclerc sera tout de même très
choqué lorsqu'il apprendra que les
français libres c'est 7001 on a tous
ratisser il ya les hommes valides de
lille 2-5 ceux qui sont contenus narvik
la légion étrangère 7000 ça n'a pas
d'importance pour leclerc
le principal c'est le vouloir et de
gaulle a déjà son rôle il sait elle a
dit que si la france peut rentrer dans
la guerre c'est par l'afrique qu'elle
fera alors par l'afrique du nord elle
est totalement rallier à vichy au
marshall pétain pas l'afrique
occidentale française c'est la même
chose le gouverneur général boissons et
vichyssois pourtant l'afrique
équatoriale a fait savoir qu'elle était
favorable à de gaulle on l'a reçu un
télégramme du gouverneur du tchad
éboué qui a dit je me rallie à vous mon
génère
on sait qu'au cameroun il ya beaucoup de
gens qui déjà ça vous se déclare
gaulliste
alors est-ce que par là on pourra pas
rentrer dans la gueule il est essentiel
d'envoyer à ses territoires des gens qui
se présenteront comme les missionnaires
de devaux de vol a déjà désigné rené
pleven delà des premiers civils qu'ils
se soient ralliés à lui le capitaine de
réserve hettier de boislambert
lorsqu'il parle avec leclerc il sent que
leclerc est l'homme de la situation
leclerc lui dis moi je voudrais en
général m'engager dans la légion
étrangère et lui répond non
vous partez pour le caméo on ne discute
pas un ordre de de gaulle le temps de
passer à la bbc de raconter son évasion
de france de se faire présenter aux
auditeurs français non pas comme le
capitaine de hauteclocque mais comme le
capitaine leclerc de gaulle lui donne un
gallon de plus si les commandants
maintenant et les veines boislambert
leclerc s'envole dans un hydravion le
claé d'honneur hydravion britannique qui
va les conduire en nigérien colonie
anglaise totalement entourée par des
colonies françaises alors évidemment si
ces colonies passe à vichy et les
anglais serait ennuyé si ces colonies se
ralliaient de gaulle ça fera plaisir aux
anglais donc les anglais ont facilité le
passage t3 envoyé de de gaulle jusqu'au
nigeria
comment passer
cameron
pour cela il faut franchir l'estuaire du
voirie il faut surtout se répartir les
tâches
on a rencontré la halle colonel de
larminat qui arrive de syrie pour se
rallier à gogo et on a décidé que pelé
venir et au tchad larminat irait à
brazzaville tandis que leclerc et
boislambert rire est au calme
[Musique]
les voilà ayant rallié autour d'une
vingtaine d'officiers et de
sous-officiers de soldats français qui
avaient fui le régime de vichy
les voilà s'embarquant dans trois
longues pirogues
on va emprunter pour rejoindre douala au
cameroun c'est rivière serpente dans la
forêt on va rejoindre l'estuaire du war
i
et on l'attend que la nuit tombe pour
gagner doit on se cache sous des halles
étudier les heures passent et un orage
éclate qui va trempé littéralement tous
ces hommes
ça n'est qu'à 3 heures du matin qu'ils
peuvent accoster
[Musique]
on se glisse le long des quais leclerc
le premier pour monter sur le quai pose
le pied sur un tronc d'arbre qui roule
sur lui-même voilà leclerc allons
boislambert aperçoit un radeau veut y
monter leurs ados bascule voilà
boislambert à l'eau tous les autres sont
trempés et voilà comment se présente le
corps expéditionnaire gaulliste à douala
quand il y arrive on rejoint la maison
d'un homme que l'on a contacté bien sûr
et puis celui ci appelle le ses
camarades gaullistes ils sont une
dizaine et centre et trouve leclerc et
boislambert il trouve non plus le
commandant leclerc et le capitaine de
boislambert mais le colonel leclerc et
le commandant de boislambert c'est que
leclerc s'est dit je vais avoir affaire
au colonel bureau qui commande les
forces de vichy il faut mots crus j'ai
le même grade que lui alors boislambert
a tout simplement décousu les galons de
sa main gauche
il en a gardé un pour lui qu'il a cousu
sur la manche droite il a donné les deux
autres à leclerc qui les a cousu à côté
des siens c'est ainsi que le capitaine
est devenu commandant et que le
commandant est devenu colonel alors les
gaullistes de wallace en plein
d'enthousiasmé même à qui réfléchit et
qui dit mais est ce que c'est bien
sérieux de tenter une affaire cette nuit
moi je pense qu'il faut préparer tout
cela pendant huit jours je crois mon
colonel l'itil à leclerc que vous
devriez partir et revenir dans huit
jours or nous qui connaissons le
caractère du leclerc ça déchaîne
immédiatement une réaction explosive
repartir et leclerc moi je suis à douala
jeunes en repartirait pas sinon les
pieds en avant
qu'on se le tienne poney alors il y
avait parmi ces gens la grand boucle de
capitaine de la coloniale qui n'avait
rien dit un tessiture et tout à coup le
voilà qui va vers la porte
voix lambert croit que les paroles
leclerc l'on hérité limay où allez-vous
et l'autre se retourne très tranquille
et dit je vais chercher ma compagne
c'est le capitaine diot qui va vivre
lui-même l'aventuré extraordinaire de
leclerc et qui lui succédera à la tête
de la 2e db plus tard et il revient avec
sa couvée grâce à cette compagnie grâce
aux gaullistes et bien dans la nuit doit
la bascule entièrement du côté de deux
routes et dans les heures qui suivent
tout le caméroun pas su opération
totalement réussi et quand de gaulle en
octobre arrivera très traumatisés de vol
car il arrive de dakar il a tiré sur ces
bateaux il a dû parti sans débarqué et
bien quand ils voient rangé sur le quai
deux bataillons impeccablement tenu une
légion de volontaires recrutés par
leclerc quand ils voient leclerc lui
même au garde à vous
au bas de l'échelle de coupée bien pour
le golf c'est un immense réconfort il
aimerait rester au cameroun il a
beaucoup de choses à faire aucun monde
l'aclu mais vous connaissez de gaulle de
gaulle lui dis ça marche très bien qu'un
monde leclerc alors je vous envoye ses
tailleurs sera le chat mais auparavant
leclerc va hasarder c'est le mot qui
convient une opération sur le gabon ne
qu'on lui avait dit le gabon et au
milieu de nos territoires
une enclave vichyste il faudrait
l'amener à nous mais attention c'est une
opération vous ne pouvez pas tenté avec
vos propres forces il faut avoir l'appui
des anglais leclerc a demandé l'appui
des anglais il n'a pas obtenu
il s'est dit pourquoi pourquoi les
anglais on peut très bien y aller de
nous mêmes et il a débarqué au gabon
malheureusement les forces p chinoises
se sont défendus il ya eu des morts on
reprochera longtemps ces morts à la clé
et il ira
je pense souvent à ces français qui sont
tombés sous les balles françaises
mais il fallait faire ça parce que
c'était utile pour la libération de la
france alors il est nommé hot chaque et
il part pour certains c'est une disgrâce
parce que qu'est-ce que c'est que le
tchad s'était pas que la savez vous
combien l'igad français au tchad en 1940
360 france alors pour quelqu'un qui
vient de mettre sur pied le pied de
guerre une colonie comme le cameroun le
tchad
c'est peu de chose non ça n'est pas une
disgrâce
parce que de gaulle qui voit très loin
toujours a dit c'est par là
c'est par le tchad que la france
rentrera dans la gu pourquoi parce que
le tchad de tous ces territoires
récemment ralliée à de gaulle est le
seul qui ait une frontière commune avec
un pays de l' axe avec la libye
italienne alors par le nord on pourra
entrer en contact avec les italiens et
se battre vécu
est arrivé au tchad leclerc ne pense
plus qu'à cela
pourtant il a passé en revue le matériel
d'armement c'est lamentable
presque rien il faut lire ces lettres
est la une où il dit oui j'ai des
camions matford malheureusement aucun
d'eux ne marche arrière
ça situe très exactement l'état de ce
matériau et pourtant il va mettre une
force sérieuse en état de combattre
il va faire venir de très loin des
équipements des armes du matériel de
l'essence il en faut elle vient de
pointe noire au congo
elle vient par voie d'eau en remontant
les fleuves par le train ensuite sur des
camions et savez vous que pour amener
dix mille litres d'essence il faut
trente mille litres 15000 pour aller
quinze mille pour revenir c'est insensé
et pourtant à fort-lamy la capitale du
tchad c'est le djamena d'aujourd'hui à
faya largeau on s'organise quel est le
projet de leclerc et bien il est allé le
dire aux chefs de tous ces postes dans
le nord là bas dans le massif du tibesti
qui osent certains sommets à plus 3000 m
il ya là des français totalement isolé
mais qui tiennent sous l'autorité du
lieutenant colonel colonna d'ornano
elle est arrivée dans ses posts parlant
aux officiers sous-officiers
parmi eux il ya un certain massue il
aurait dit on va attaquer pour les
autres nous regardent et que avec
stupeur attaqué quoi avec
on n'a rien attaquer les italiens de
l'autre côté de la frontière et il
explique oui on va attaquer à koufra
alors là ils se disent tous le colonel
est complètement fou parce qu'ils savent
très bien ce que ça représente koufra
c'est la dernière conquête des italiens
en libye ne date que de 1931 ça a été
très dur parce que autochtones se défend
des vaches man ka dia ni à utiliser des
forces énormes 3000 hommes 7000 chameau
300 avions 200 camions
il a fallu tout cela pour venir à bout
de la région de koufra avec toutes ces
oasis si riche si fertile et quand les
italiens avaient gagné ça avait été
les fanfares de la victoire grazziani
s'était écrié les italiens sont les plus
grands colonisateur du monde à côté
d'eux les français les anglais ne sont
que des enfants
[Musique]
il savait ça les gens perdus dans les
postes utile et ch'ti et d'ailleurs
alors quand leclerc leur dit on va
attaquer à koufra guy lille et vous
maniez hip hop et eelv attaque
et cette colère hétéroclite ces vieux
camions dont les différentes parties
tiennent à peine ensemble c'est deux
canons de 75
c'est toute l'artillerie mme ses
voitures et ses hommes montez vers le
nord
il affronte le désert savez vous combien
de kilomètres a parcouru la force armée
de leclerc à son départ de faial âge
dans une journée en 24 heures quatre que
les salles désertique et pourtant on
avance
[Musique]
en franchit les camps et c'est leclerc
lui même avec 20 voitures qui décide
d'aller en reconnaissance vers koufra et
il voit koufra à sa portée
[Musique]
d'ailleurs il détruit au sol des avions
italiens des dépôts d'essence et il sait
qu'on peut tenter l'opération
il revient en arrière rassemble les
forces et toutes les forces arrive près
du fort
qui marque le point
central de la défense du coffre
on met le siège autour de ses fins
[Musique]
un seul canon de 75 est arrivé jusque là
on ouvre le feu sur le feu on déplace
sans arrêt ce canon de 75 pour donner
l'illusion aux italiennes que vous
disposez d'une très forte harpie et les
nerfs des items y accèdent aux goudes
diouf un drapeau blanc s'élève sur le
mât une fort à la place du drapeau
italien
on voit sortir un plénipotentiaire du
fort qui vient jusqu'aux lignes
françaises leclerc est en tournée à ce
moment là quand il rentre il voit
l'italien du qu'est-ce que vous faites
là il gagne un dhimmi le capitaine
colonna qui commande le fort
souhaiterais savoir à quelles conditions
nous pourrions négocier négocier dit
leclaire et à ce moment-là il pousse
l'italien dans un véhicule saute lui
même dans le véhicule donne l'ordre
chauffeur de foncer sur le fort vous
avez tous les italiens qui étaient là
qui voyait qu'ils regardaient de long à
leur plein potentiel
les coudes appuyé sur les murailles et
qui voit stupéfiants a levé cette
voiture à toute allure la porte du fort
est restée ouverte
la voiture de la paire s'engouffre
rentrer dans le fer et le capitaine
italien arrive le capitaine colonna une
réflexion qui méritent d'être cités
india leclerc mais vous n'aviez pas le
droit je suis là dit leclaire giresse
alors vous voulez vous rendre non dit
colonna je voulais discuter bon
j'accepte votre reddition et le
capitaine italien va signer la reddition
résultat tout le matériel tout larmes
tous les vivres et tout cela est
considérable tout tombe aux mains des
français
c'est la première victoire française
depuis l'armistice de 40 alors les
italiens sont prisonniers et après avoir
envoyé un télégramme à de gaulle leclerc
par là ces hommes au pas un discours
innopolis cours quelques mots et parmi
les mots qu'il prononce il ya cette
phrase qui passera totalement inaperçu
n'y a pas un journal qui l'a reproduira
à l'époque pas une radio qu'il affronte
en jurant de ne déposer les armes que
lorsque nos trois couleurs flotteront
sur le clocher de la cathédrale de
strasbourg
voilà oui c'est ce qu'on a appelé le
serment de koufra
il est content leclerc mai
at il tellement de raison de l'être
parce que la guerre tourne pas bien
la guerre des avions allemands survole
le désert de cyrénaïque de nouvelles
troupes monde dans ligne des unités
italiennes en action contre naples et
anglaise
il yad'autres saloum première place
corps de britanniques en territoire
égyptien est enlevé par les troupes
germano-italienne les italiens épaules
et bientôt par e mail et si romaine qui
gagne écrase les anglais l'afrique du
nord
[Musique]
la longue colonne des prisonniers
anglais en marche vers derna
[Musique]
la russie comme l'avait prévu de gaulle
est entré en guerre mais les troupes
d'hitler fonce vers moscou
les etats unis également sont en guerre
mais cette guerre a commencé par
terrible désastre à pearl harbour alors
alors leclerc garde sa confiance absolue
comme de gauche pour ça ils sont
totalement pareil et c'est que de toute
façon c'est dans son camp que viendra la
victoire il veut collaborer à cette
victoire
alors maintenant la prochaine opération
il est en train de la préparer
il veut foncer sur le fait ça le fun
c'est une région de la libye italienne
grande comme la moitié de la france
mais sillonnée par un excellent réseau
de routes et dans cette guerre d'afrique
du nord
les transports c'est capital et le coeur
s'est dit que portait la pagaille dans
les transports allemand et italien se
serait tout de même une belle russe
naturellement leclerc d'accord avec les
anglais on est convenus que lui-même
attaquera lorsque les anglais contre
attaquerons l'armée de romell pour en
venir à bout définitivement et au mois
d'octobre 1940 2 c'est ce qui se produit
et leclerc fonce sur le fezzan
le voilà qu'arrive une nouvelle
miraculeux le 8 novembre 1942 les
américains viennent de débarquer en
afrique du nord
voilà que tout est en train de tourner
et voilà qui prouve que leclerc avait
raison et lui l' attaque
et successivement il s'empare de tous
les postes d'italiens du fait
[Musique]
c'est une extraordinaire réussite il
s'empare lui même de la capitale du
fezzan avec 201 hisse le drapeau
tricolore
il lui reste deux postes après gâte et
ghadamès gala mais s'il s'en charge
il ne peut pas en même temps prendre
garde et savez vous ce qu'il va faire
depuis le débarquement américain avec
darlan d'abord avec giraud ensuite et
pour finir avec tout gaulle et bien
l'afrique du nord vichyssoise est elle
même retraités alors de l'autre côté de
la frontière il ya un poste français de
troupes qui la veille encore été
vichyssoise de gaulle envoie un
plénipotentiaire à ce poste et demande à
l'office y est qu'il comment voulez-vous
prendre gâte à la joie de cet officier
la joie de ses hommes
et ils prennent gâte après avoir envoyé
un message à leclerc nous sommes fiers
de combattre les années
[Musique]
et un détachement des ex vichyssois va
rencontrer les français pour leclerc
c'est la voie ouverte à la
réconciliation des français
oui peut-être mais enfin il faudra du
temps
alors maintenant la leclerc qui du fait
de logorrhée néral fonce vers tripoli et
rejoint montgomery voilà les deux hommes
face à face montgomery qui félicite
leclerc et qui va créer pour lui une
force spéciale la force elle
qui va combattre aux côtés des anglais
contre la ligne la fameuse ligne
m'arrête qui barre l'accès de la tunisie
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
quelques mois plus tard quand montgomery
présentera leclerc au roi george vi
d'angleterre il dira si voici le général
leclerc
sans lui je n'aurais pas pris la ligne
marrec c'est peut-être une politesse un
peu exagéré il l'aurait prise quand même
la ligne m'arrête mais qu'il l'ait dit
déjà c'est quelque chose qui compte pour
nous qui compte pour l'histoire de notre
pays
leclerc sera dans gabès la première
ville française libérée en tunisie il
rencontrera giraud heroes pile
l'accueillera avec sympathie mais
l'appellera s'obstinera à l'appeler
hauteclocque comme si leclerc n'avait
jamais existé et il n'y a pas vraiment
d'atomes crochus entre les deux âmes la
preuve c'est qu'on va envoyer la force
elle loue repos à tripoli le repos pour
les hommes de leclerc ont leur peau pour
leclerc c'est quelque chose qui ne
convient pas heureusement on annonce
qu'une division blindée va être créée et
confiée à la clé ce sera la 2e db
les hommes de la force elles vont
traverser l'afrique du nord de parents
partent pour rejoindre le maroc puisque
c'est là qu'elle est formée la 2e db et
leclerc tiendra à composer cette
division d'officiers et d'hommes venus
aussi bien la france libre que des
anciennes troupes de vichy
au début ce ne sera pas sans heurts ces
gens ne s'aiment pas on le comprend il y
a eu aussi ces jeunes gens qui ont
déserté de l'armée de giro pour
rejoindre leclerc ça ne paie pas ces
choses là mais finalement grâce à
leclerc grâce à son énergie grâce à son
ascendant à son autorité et bien l'
amalgame se fera et un état d'esprit se
créera l'esprit de la 2e db qui survivra
à tous elle est en place elle est formée
elle est entraînée cette 2ème db c'est
une très belle force
alors où ira-t-elle logiquement ce
devrait être en italie où les français
se battent mais de vol a une autre
vision de l'avenir du proche avait il
sait que les alliés vont les barques et
à l'ouest
il sait qu'ils vont débarquer en france
probablement en normandie et il veut
qu'il y ait des français qui souhaitent
avec les alliés à ce moment là pour lui
c'est capital
et il a demandé à sézanne horaire le
commandant suprême le généralissime il a
demandé à nos horaires autorisés la 2e
db a débarqué en france et appuyés par
churchill
il a obtenu satisfaction alors la 2e db
on la transporte en angleterre elle est
dans le yorkshire elle est intégrée à la
célèbre armée du général pas très elle a
un dernier entraînement de deux ultimes
manoeuvres
c'est le 6 juin
car le débarque
[Musique]
à
alors ces français attend avec
impatience que nous devinons tous
fiévreuse fébrile c'est demain qu'on va
partir on ne part pas c'est après demain
on ne part pas sûr non si la semaine
prochaine on ne part pas
[Musique]
ils ne sont partis que le 31 juillet en
se disant mais on va arriver après la
bataille alors à quoi bon tout ça
[Musique]
le premier ou leclerc s'ouvre sur le
sable est normal et il s'arrête il
bougonne drôle d'impression
et puis tout à coup détendu
on est quand même bien content
et la 2e db est engagé dans la bataille
[Musique]
lors d'une manoeuvre qu'elle combat
c'est la bataille autour des couches et
elle va mettre en pièces trois divisions
blindés allemands
[Musique]
maintenant leclerc n'a plus qu'une
hantise marine qui délivrera paris il en
a parlé plusieurs fois au commandement
américain dont il dépend lui a dit oui
on y pense
je voudrais que ce soit des français du
leclerc
oui oui on y pense et on fait qu'ils
pensent et le 19 août 1944
leclerc apprend que le plan des noves
n'est pas de prendre paris mais de
contourner paris par le nord par le sud
pourquoi et bien parce qu'on ne veut pas
perdre de temps à se battre dans paris
on veut poursuivre les allemands et puis
on ne veut pas non plus nourrir les
parisiens parce que ça perdrait un temps
terrible parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'il n'ya que quelques jours de vivre
paris les éleveurs c'est libre mon
travail c'est de gagner la guerre contre
les allemands pas de nourrir les
parisiens alors leclerc se demande ce
qui va se passer mais est-ce qu'on va
abandonner paris et le lendemain il
apprend que paris vient justement de
s'insurger
in asie il n'a jamais hésité logo il
donne immédiatement l'ordre au colonel
de guillebon de foncer vers ben pourtant
il fait partie d'une armée américaine
il n'a demandé l'autorisation à personne
apte d'un discipline camping et le
poison et voilà que son chef le général
jérôme est fou furieux
il s'est dit ce serait peut-être pas mal
d'allers parlementer avec le général
bradley l'adjoint immédiate dans les
annuaires il saute dans son piper club
voilà chez bradley on me dit mais non
général bradley est avec le général
eisenhower il n'est pas là c'est vrai
que par les partis chez eisenach
pourquoi et bien pour rencontrer de
gaulle figure et parce qu'il n'ya pas
que leclerc qui s'est inquiété il y a
plusieurs jours que de gaulle négocié
que de gaulle demande que paris soit
libérés soit secouru et depuis
l'insurrection de paris qu'il est là or
einsenhower vient de recevoir des
informations sur par l'une des raisons
qui l'avait encouragé à contourner paris
c'est qu'il croyait devoir se battre
dans paris et y laisser beaucoup de
plumes craignais qu'il y une force
redoutable
du côté allemand dans paris or ces
informations lui signale ya très peu de
soldats allemands n'en paraît
relativement peu
et puis surtout le consul de suède
monsieur nordling qui a négocié une
trêve entre la résistance et les
allemands fait connaître aux américains
que le général von choltitz qui commande
les forces allemandes de paris n'est pas
du tout un foudre de guerre
il a reçu l'ordre d'hitler de détruire
tous les ponts de paris de résister
jusqu'au dernier homme il n'a pas
l'intention d'obéir
pourquoi parce que c'est un homme lucide
il a compris que hitler avait déjà perdu
la guerre à quoi bon détruire l'une des
plus belles villes du monde et faire
mourir beaucoup de gens alors ça change
tout et einsenhower dit oui à de grands
nous allons libérer paraît et quand de
gaulle ajoute il faudrait que ce soit la
2ème db qui libère paris einsenhower
répond d'accord bradley saute dans son
avion pour regagner son état major
il trouve sur le terrain leclerc qui
ronge son frein depuis des heures
les deux hommes sont l'un en face de
l'autre et bras b duquel chance leclerc
je voulais vous envoyer un message
il faut que vous partiez il faut que
votre division font sur paris
[Musique]
alors leclerc entre
chez lui au milieu de ses hommes
l'ordre est donné on part demain 6h on
ne croyait pas que ce fut une promenade
militaire bien sûr les colonnes de
leclerc vont rouler sur des routes
[Musique]
flanqué d'un peuple enthousiaste des
lions
[Musique]
mais à plusieurs endroits il faudra
affronter les allemands
les allemands king plusieurs fois ils
n'ont pas du tout l'intention de céder
le terrain sans combattre
et c'est affreux
que leclerc par rejoindre le colonel
drones qui comme les ordres l'indiquent
fait manoeuvre père orléans je lui dit
vous n'allez pas à orléans vous allez
sur paris foncé tout droit la colonne
drone sera la première à rentrer dans
paris le soir est tombé et ce sera la
folle chevauchée jusqu'à l'hôtel de
ville j'en appelle aux souvenirs de ceux
qui étaient là comme moi d'ailleurs
qu'ils se souviendront toujours
l'accueil des hommes de leclerc des
hommes venus du chat pour libérer la
france et les cloches de parkison toutes
les églises de paris qui sonne en même
temps je l'entendrai toujours ce fracas
ce bonheur
toutes les cloches de toutes les églises
sauf celle de saint philippe du roule
pour une raison bien simple il n'y a pas
de clos chassaing philippe duron et le
lendemain c'est toute la division qui
rentre dans paris et qui va combattre
toute la journée on a oublié ça on se
souvient que des jeunes filles en blanc
qui sautait sur les chars qui embrassait
les soldats de leclerc oui bien sûr il
ya eu ça mes yeux il abat tard
car les allemands maintenant s'était
retranché dans plusieurs points très
solidement tenue il a fallu les prendre
les uns après les autres
[Musique]
moi qui habitait près de l'école
militaire je me souviens toujours de ces
longues heures cette can am de ses coups
de feu échangés pendant des heures
[Musique]
et puis leur est arrivé où on a amené un
général prisonnier à leclerc le général
von choltitz et le dialogue qui s'engage
etes-vous le général von choltitz oui je
suis le général leclerc et l'acte de
reddition qui est signé un second acte
qui est signée au quartier général de la
gare montparnasse et la leclerc voudra y
associer le colonel rol chef des
insurgés parisien le lendemain c'est le
défilé
de l'étoile à notre dame
[Musique]
il est fait
plafond 2 millions sûrement de parisiens
couru de tous les quartiers de paris
et là comme dans un état second de
gaulle qui s'avance au milieu de cette
marée humaine flanqué de leclerc et de
konig l'homme de miracle
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
il
la 2e db va repartir mais auparavant
leclerc saute dans ce conflit par coop
qui atterrit à taillis
chez lui
on n'a pas revu sa femme et ses enfants
depuis juin 1940
et il repart est la 2ème db va se battre
dans l'est
inutile de suivre son itinéraire jalonné
de combat victorieux la prise de
baccarat c'est le succès qui sera le
plus cher à leclerc
[Musique]
et enfin strasbourg
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
strasbourg libérer enfin redevenu
français et le drapeau tricolore comme
il l'avait promis à koufra qui flottent
là haut clocher de la cathédrale
entre temps on en voyait prendre royan
une poche occupée par les allemands mais
il est de retour pour la campagne
d'allemagne et ce sont les hommes de la
2ème db qui vont prendre symboliquement
et c'est un romancier n'oserait pas
l'imaginer berchtesgaden le dit d'elle
le quartier général hitler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
officiers sous-officiers soldats de la
2e division blindée
il ya quelques jours j'avais l'honneur
de défiler dans votre tête dans ce pari
nous l'avons libéré aujourd'hui je viens
vous faire mes adieux nouveau type
je ne quitterai pas le signe de votre
division ne conserveraient ce sera ma
plus belle décoration c'est fini pour
leclerc sa carrière pourrait s'arrêter
là
non on a encore besoin de lui
on a besoin leclerc en indochine
pourquoi parce que depuis 1940
le japon a occupé la loge et maintenant
le japon après hiroshima et nagasaki
s'est incliné le japon reconnaît qu'il a
perdu la guerre leclerc par et puisqu'il
est en extrême orient
et bien c'est lui qui va avoir l'honneur
insigne
de signer sur le cuirassé missouri pour
la france l'acte de capitulation du
japon
alors on a deux chine 160 mille chinois
ont remplacé les japonais les chinois
qui n'ont pas du tout l'intention de
rendre l'indochine et leclerc va montrer
qu'il n'est pas seulement un grand
soldat mais un fin stratège politique
il négocie l'obtient et c'était très
difficile
le départ des gis il va rentrer dans un
homme à la tête des troupes françaises
follement acclamé par les quinze mille
français qui avaient passé là les quatre
n'est de guerre dans des conditions
souvent très crues est très applaudi
aussi par les vietnamiens qu'ils
préféraient les français aux chinois au
début il était arrivé en indochine
imprégné des traditions coloniale de
l'armée française pour lui c'est une
colonie qu'on avait perdu et qu'on
devait récupérer mais il va vite
comprendre qu'il se passe autre chose en
indochine il va rencontrer hô chi minh
je ne dis pas qu'il aura pour origine
une sympathie débordant mais il aura
pour lui beaucoup d estime de même que
pour le japon
et savez vous quel est le français
investies d'une autorité important qui a
le premier écrit pour le gouvernement
français
un mot à propos de l'indochine ce mot
cette indépendance
c'est sous la plume de leclerc leclerc
qui était maurrassien autrefois leclerc
l'homme de toutes les traditions mais il
a compris et vous savez c'est impossible
de refaire l'histoire de dire mais si on
avait écouté le klay lui voulait qu'on
négocie l'amiral thierry d'argenlieu
n'allait pas aussi loin que leclerc
alors le clairet partie en 1946
ce sont ces premières vacances atterri
au milieu des siens
je crois que nous pouvons adresser une
pensée à la général leclerc parce que
cette femme était séparée de son mari
depuis le début de la guerre elle avait
pu croire lorsque la guerre s'était
achevée qu'elle allait retrouver son
mari et son mari étaient aussitôt parti
pour l'ado j'ai maintenant il est là
près d'elle près des enfants
[Musique]
il va tout de même repartir pour la
logique en mission parce que hô chi minh
estimera que les français n'ont dupe et
il lèvera l'étendard de la rébellion
on appelle au secours leclerc je
retourne là bas fait un rapport au
gouvernement français on ne tiendra
l'indochine qui veut à tout prix son
indépendance qu'en mobilisant le
contingent il sait très bien que la
quatrième république ses débuts n'a ni
les moyens ni le désir ni la volonté de
mobiliser le contingent donc lorsqu'il
écrit il faudrait mobiliser le
contingent cela veut dire vous n'avez
qu'une solution négociée traité on
n'écoutera pas une fois de plus il
rentrera et juin lui proposant
l'inspection les forces armées à
l'afrique du nord il acceptera avec joie
parce que l'afrique du nord c'est toute
sa vie
désormais chaque mois il va en afrique
du nord
47 les vacances encore atteint au milieu
de ces bois de ces fermes de ses champs
je vous ai dit qu'il y avait toujours de
la terre sous les semelles du
gentilhomme campagne à philippe doc
clock
en novembre on l'appelle à strasbourg
pour le troisième anniversaire de la
libération de la ville et alors là la
liberté pour les strasbourgeois
elle s'appelle le plein l'alsace se
souvient strasbourg avec une émotion
profonde a fêté ses libérateurs ceux de
la 2e division blindée
ce qui pour toute l'alsace sont restés
les leclerc
le général leclerc fidèle au serment des
sables de coupe 1 au terme de la longue
route de la délivrance hissait sur la
cathédrale de strasbourg
le pipeau de la france
[Applaudissements]
il s'arrache à strasbourg on l'attend
l'afrique du nord
le voilà à oran où il assiste à des
manoeuvres
et puis le 27 novembre au terrain
d'aviation d'oran et s'envole vers la
mort nous en venons à la question posée
au début de notre entretien
comment expliquer cette main plan nous
savons que perdus dans le sable
à un moment le pilote avait cherché à se
retrouver dans la direction de colomb
béchar en sortant de cette crasse pour
suivre la voie ferrée du méditerranée
niger et à témoin a vu l'avion passer à
10 mètres au dessus d'une gare sebha
bible est un peu plus loin
l'avion a percuté le remblai de la voie
verte
remblai qui s'élevait à 4 mètres de
hauteur
[Musique]
l'explosion l'incendié la mort de tous
ses hommes
quand on entend ces témoignages on s'est
dit ben oui c'est un accident
et puis on se souvient si c'est un
accident pourquoi un treizième cada le
rapport de la commission denquête envoyé
immédiatement sur place de colomb béchar
a bien dénombré 13 cadavres
et puis à l'état civil il ya un acte de
décès non pas pour 12 personnes mais
pour 13 et le 13e c'est un inconnu
désigné comme le lieutenant x
et puis tous savons que on l'a
transporté 13 cada et a aucun doute
alors on a donné des explications
on a parlé de passager clandestin
il est impossible qu'il y est eu un
passager clandestin pourquoi parce que
pourrait-il plus cacher seulement dans
la soute à bomber
or on ne pouvait accéder à la soute
abonde que par le poste d'équipage
or l'avion étaient gardés l'équipage
était là dans l'avion avant qu'arrive le
klay par conséquent impossible de se
cacher alors on s'est dit mais est ce
que ce ne serait pas quelqu'un qui
serait monté dans l'avion au dernier
moment parfaitement à la connaissance de
l'équipage et du général c est une
hypothèse séduisante mais il est très
difficile de la retenir
pourquoi parce que tous les gens que
leclerc a chargé dans son avion dans de
telles occasions étaient des militaires
n'était pas possible pour un homme comme
leclerc de prendre un civil sur un
appareil militaire
or un militaire un corps le lendemain il
aurait été porté manquant
on aurait fait une enquête on aurait
fait le rapprochement
et on aurait su que c'était lui qui
était dans l'avion le 13e cada alors
alors il ya une autre explication et si
c'était bien un passagers accueillis par
leclerc au dernier moment mais membre
des services spéciaux un homme chargé
d'une mission que connaissait que
l'avion se brise l'avion brûle il y un
13ème cadavres les services secret
savent parfaitement de qui il s'agit
mais pour des raisons supérieures secret
défense
eh bien on ne dira pas qui de toutes les
hypothèses j'estime que c'est la plus
plausible mais il y en a d'autres
presque aussitôt je voulais dit tout à
l'heure on a employé un mot redoutable
on a usé d'un redoutable attentat alors
un attentat bon mais qui aurait intérêt
à vouloir en novembre 1947 supprimer le
général leclerc
alors il faut que tout de même se
souvient qu'au retour d'indochine
leclerc était un homme désabusé leclerc
n'était pas un homme heureux
pendant ces quatre années de combat
d'espoir il avait rêvé d'une autre
france il avait écrit à de gaulle
il ne faudra pas que la france retombe
dans les errements qui ont conduit à la
défaite de 40
la france s'était pas du tout diriger
vers cette perspective dont il rêvait
les français s'étaient donnés en 46 une
constitution absurde qui aggraveraient
l'instabilité de la ive république qui
affaiblissent et l'exécutif
le général de gaulle pour protester
contre cette constitution avait quitté
le pouvoir était entré dans sa retraite
à colombey-les-deux-églises ce n'était
pas ça qu avez-vous lu leclerc quand ils
se battaient à coups francs ou dans le
fezzan alors e leclerc ne parlait pas
c'était un soldat
l'obligation de réserve il s'y tenait
farouchement mais on savait qu'il
n'était pas d'accord
en 1947 monsieur ramadier s'était séparé
des ministres communistes immédiatement
avait commencé avec l'appui de cgt une
immense vague de grèves
alors certes on penser que le parti
communiste aurait à l'époque grain
justement que l'on lougheed appelle le
cloud d'autant plus qu'il semble bien
que le président du conseil ramadier et
vu le clair pour lui dire en cas de coup
dur
mon général est ce qu'on peut compter
sur vous leclerc semble-t-il a refusé
mais on l'a su tout cela alors un
général un soldat il y a dans l'histoire
de la france
des références historiques que la gauche
n'a jamais admise mais de là à supprimer
leclerc peut-on l'envisager à moins que
l'ordre e et l'agent d'exécution soit
venu de moscou de moscou règne à
l'époque staline et staline est capable
de tout voilà l'hypothèse que certains
avancent et il y en a une autre
elle a été présentée par conrad clients
personnages extraordinaires qui avait
bien avant la guerre des sla d'immenses
gisements de pétrole dans les sables du
fezzan après la guerre est bien la libye
avait été confiée la libye talent yen
avait été confiée à la grande bretagne
mais le fait en conquis par leclerc
avait été remis à la france
malheureusement la grande-bretagne
souhaitait beaucoup que le fait en ne
soit définitivement attribuées et conrad
keely on savait qu'on était prêt à céder
alors il avait écrit à leclerc et puis
il était allé voir le club lui avait dit
vous n'allez pas laisser faire ça en
général nous savons par des témoins que
leclerc était sortie de l'entrevue
furieux alors conrad keely ans après la
mort de leclerc s'est écrié c'est
l'angleterre qui a tué le claix et il
est vrai qu'après la mort de leclerc le
président robert schuman
s'est incliné devant le désir
britannique il a dit après tu du fezzan
il a dit après tout ce n'est que du
sable
alors là aussi peut-on poser la question
les anglais faire mourir leclerc là
semble également impossible à admettre
on nous aura dit que dans le passé
certains services anglais étaient
capables d'actes for tomorrow c'est vrai
mais leclerc de toute façon s'il y
attentats ça n'explique pas le troisième
cadavre
bien sûr quelqu'un pouvait déposer une
bombe dans la viande leclerc une bombe à
retardement
mais pourquoi voulez vous que ce
quelqu'un monte dans l'avion il n'a pas
besoin d'être là pour que la bombe
éclate et même il n'a pas envie d'être
là puisque le l'avion va sauter toute
façon alors le 13e can have ne
s'explique pas c'est pourquoi à mon sens
nous devons éliminer l'hypothèse de
l'attentât et revenir à l'hypothèse de
l'accident
le 13e cadavres étant celui d'un agent
secret connu de leclerc voilà je crois à
quelle conclusion doit aboutir
aujourd'hui l'historien la vérité était
que leclerc toute sa vie s'était refusé
à plier devant les hommes a plié devant
les événements ce jour là il n'a pas
voulu plier devant les éléments un jour
il avait dit tout ce que j'ai fait de
bien dans la vie tout ce que j'ai réussi
c'est parce que j'ai désobéi
il avoue lui désobéir aux éléments et
c'est pourquoi emma philippe doc clock
celui dont le parlement allait faire un
maréchal de france mais qui pour
l'éternité restera le général leclerc
[Musique]